We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I got a lot of voicemails about this recent
Bill Maher segment.
Take a listen to this.
Haiti on the most recent episode of Bill Maher's
show on January 30th, he had two evolutionary
biologists on that.
Not only said that they were 90 percent sure
the coronavirus started in the lab, but they
looked a little bit confused at one of the
rest of the world.
Doesn't think that I was wondering if you
had heard anything about science thinking
this.
I actually saw the segment and the two evolutionary
biologists that the caller is referring to
are Brett Weinstein.
And I think it's his wife, Heather Hying Heying.
I'm not sure how to pronounce it.
I did see the segment on Bill Maher.
And they they made statements to the to the
tone of they think it's quite plausible that
the coronavirus was made in a lab in China
either, and it could have been released or
maybe it got out.
And I you know, I've exchanged a few messages
over the years with Bret Weinstein.
I've invited him on the program before and
he's never taken me up on it.
To me, those comments are not the ones I look
to when I try to.
You know, I would go to a virologist and other
folks who specialize in viruses for opinions
about whether there's any reason to believe
that covid was manmade and or released on
purpose or accidentally from a Chinese lab.
I don't know where evolutionary biologists
are are getting the framework with which to
say things like what Brett and Heather said.
And my view continues to be that of what virologists
are saying, which are and I'm summarizing
here, while it has not been definitively disproven
that covid could have come from a lab, there
is no evidence at this point in time to believe
that that's the case.
And that's my position right now.
And everybody else can sort of judge for themselves
what they think are reasonable, irresponsible
comments to be to be making about that.
I am not trying to suppress anyone's speech.
I don't think it's something that should be
you know, nobody should be barred from investigating
the origins of the virus.
And that's my understanding of the consensus
of virology at this.
Point in time, we've got a great bonus show
for you today, get instant access by becoming
a member at join Pakman Dotcom.